millions of americans are running into
obstacles as they try to get vaccinated
during these deadliest days of the
pandemic we've seen
lines like these at dodger stadium in
los angeles
where people reportedly waited up to
five hours to get vaccinated
around 37 million doses have been
delivered but the cdc says
only about 17 million have been given
out so far
amid complaints of a dwindling supply at
vaccination sites
carter evans has more from hard hit
glendale arizona
as supply shortages force closures and
cancellations at vaccination sites
nationwide
frustrations are growing with the lack
of information from state
and federal leaders whether it's a
family-owned pharmacy in pennsylvania
towards the end of last week i asked for
a thousand doses and
they couldn't give me any kind of answer
or a city-run site in garland texas
we do not have any notifications pending
for
our next shipment of either when it will
arrive or how much it will be
while reports of supply shortages grow
the latest cdc data shows just
22 states and washington d.c have used
more than half of their received doses
this feels very contradictory that
only half the doses have been used and
yet cities are saying we need more
but they're both true dr ashish jah is
dean of the brown school of public
health
so what explains that discrepancy there
are two sets of issues going on and one
is
there's a bunch of vaccines that have
been allocated to hospitals to nursing
homes that are just not
getting delivered into people's arms but
of course they can't take those vaccines
back
from those places these mega sites that
cities and states are creating
those are running well their main
problem is they just don't have enough
doses
and that's just for adults the vaccine
still isn't approved for children
and pediatric cases are soaring in
arizona
which leads the nation with covet
infections in kids
and pediatric hospitalizations here are
up more than 400 percent
since october they can go anywhere from
just needing a little bit of oxygen and
some iv
fluids all the way to needing a
ventilator
life-threatening lung and heart disease
there have been deaths in arizona from
covid
in children eight-year-old juliette
hernandez tested positive after she was
hospitalized
fortunately she survived but her parents
say it was a long road to recovery
we ended up being there 15 days you
don't want
your kid to be the one getting sick
now some of the most severe
complications in children comes from
multi-system
inflammatory syndrome that can happen up
to six weeks after a child has recovered
from coven
now when it comes to the vaccine here in
arizona they've used less than half of
their available doses
even as mass vaccination sites have
every appointment booked up
for weeks tony time to use them if you
got them carter thank you very much